if donald trump was selected by god as  you are certain that he was  why would god allow joe biden to even  become president and force you to go  through all of this why not just put  trump in the white house again well i  believe i believe that that's that's  part of this divine divine thing that's  going on because really people don't  look let me tell you people do not look  for hope unless things are going bad  and this that's why i believe this will  be the greatest revival for jesus and we  will be once again one nation under god  ever because all these people including  yourself are going to see miracles  unfold here mike are you saying even  even even a jewish guy like me will see  jesus  okay  what's that even a jewish guy like me  you're gonna see miracles you're gonna  see miracles unfold  you're gonna see miracles unfold you can  believe whatever you want but you're  gonna see things that you thought were  impossible okay happened